ciao la cosa più stupida che abbia mai
fatto è stata quando avevo 7 anni ed
andava centri estivi
c'era sempre una bambina che non voleva
mai farsi il bagno in piscina ed io non
me le capacitavo non riuscivo a capire
come una persona non sapesse nuotare
allora un giorno decise di spingerla in
acqua e rimasi via ad osservarlo anche
l'animatore non si tocca a noi per far
male ma sei un mostro state praticamente
questa puntata legarsi anche potenziali
omicidi
mannaggia ciao ragazzi bentornati una
puntata di vita buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi è la cosa più stupida
che ho fatto che mai
ciao ragazzi ben tornati ad una puntata
di vita buttata il tema della puntata di
oggi è la cosa più stupida che ho mai
fatto dopo mesi e mesi di pausa
finalmente si ritorna sono molto
contento anche perché per parlare di un
tema così importante l'unica persona che
forse in questo momento di delirio gray
accolto all'interno degli studios di
casa mia che oggi sanno di discarica
abusiva è prima di tutto un amico oltre
che diciamo un collega in quella che
un'esperienza che stiamo vivendo insieme
che forse è la cosa meno stupidi abbiamo
fatto che la nostra vita sto parlando di
marco cioni dell'asl indossa ciao allora
marco al volessimo diciamo che è da un
po di mesi che abbiamo fondato un club
del libro si che si chiama la setta dei
libri si per darle così una delle
punterie un po di stupidità nella sera
esatto un allure un pochino demoniaco ed
è fondamentalmente diventato un account
su instagram e come funziona
praticamente ogni mese scegliamo un
libro da leggere e lo leggiamo insieme
agli utenti e poi alla fine del mese
facciamo un incontro mentre durante mese
discutiamo su instagram
di solito i libri li proponiamo oggi è
guglielmo e poi l'utente finale
scegliere quale dei due atto di solito
il libro che vince a quello mio dire che
sei stato veramente a chiaro è vero non
parleremo però di libri oggi ma
parleremo di cose stupide
partiamo subito ascoltare gli audio e
poi se te la senti di di aprirti
commettere
ma giornale dire in privato devo andare
siete decentrati e dove cazzo andare
adesso al centro estivo praticamente
c'erano questi lunghi toboga di scivoli
acquatici allora quei miei amici
facciamo una gara che arrivava più
veloce in fondo quindi di pancia di
ginocchia provato in tutti i modi
un mio amico si gira e mi fa mi
raccomando di fuori rai come vai veloce
esco fisicamente il qb fuori mi siedo e
noto subito che un disastro quindi io
vado velocissimo vincola gara arrivo il
fondo che se l'acqua per fermarti
kristen è l'atto che fa paura e per una
settimana io l'ho praticamente la parte
pratica la cosa più stupida che abbia
mai fatto adottare la vita non la
possiamo non è fatta fare un piste
dell'acqua quando arrivi in fondo c'è
l'acqua ferma e tu invece arriva
velocità penetri l'acqua e l'acqua
quindi ripetuti certi che rimane così ma
dipende cosa mi fai prima di farsi se
siete di mal di pancia guarda martino
scivola fuori e addio
guardai non lo so se può essere
considerata una tra di assumere sotto
buongiorno a tutti
io faccio l'assistente volo che sto
lavorando è venuto un bambino dietro le
due andare al bagno da solo ma questo ci
hanno avuto canzone che dieci anni che
ho detto basta da sola a talita casa no
no è entrato in bagno non tocca a posto
ho visto quando non riusciva ad uscire
perché la porta ci aveva che vista lo
che si girava e si era impiccato invece
di aiutarlo io lo trovo chiuso in bagno
almeno cinque minuti boni che stavano lì
campani classe così ho detto prosciolta
ten pari a rispondere vale quando ero
chiesto soltanto se stavi da solo
aspettando che mario stavamo alternare
tirarlo fuori
manila e river prigioniero ad alta quota
però ero bambino poi inizia la
non eravamo piccoli ci annoiavamo e
avevamo dei telefoni e delle pagine
bianche con l'elenco delle persone qui
abbiamo grande re pagine bianche che
erano le vostre menti talmente bianche e
qui abbiamo detto mettiamo su
un'attività chiamiamo le persone e
creiamo del caos erano i joker di romano
il nostro obiettivo era creare questa
storia in cui noi eravamo dei bambini
abusati e una persona chiamava al
viscusi cesi al face fingendo di aver
sbagliato numero
in sottofondo dietro c'era questo falso
papà ti prego basta
le persone che rispondevano di ciano è
un problema ci fosse aiutarti
no no guardi sono sbagliato numero
cacciano anche richiamato non esisteva
ancora il numero privato e ha disposto
un genitore e lì è stato problematiche
ha capito di cui l'alta attività è
fallita lì ci hanno detto no perché
sentiamo un po sentiamo bambino e veniva
archi ato però il vostro titoli poteva
sembrare che stesse bene per il cielo è
raga delinquere adesso ci sono questi
gli amici che non vede il padre da via g
davvero un giorno a casa da sole non era
andata a scuola e avevo fame non sapevo
cosa mangiare ho preso quattro pacchi di
pop corn e video mangiati tu il mezzo
che mangiavo dovere qualcosa bruciato a
bere un po di alcolici vi sono ubriacati
fatto male e c'è voluto il tutto rischia
di tutti che schifo
cosa ebbe con limoncello volta champagne
il che ad un certo punto non riusciva
più a camminare in poi mi risveglio così
a caso nella vasca il trap è stati
maschera per i capelli
comunque dopo mica tanto
però se c'è ottimo già bene è
un'immagine stupenda
grazie grazie mille cosa più stupida e
non mi ha mai fatto è stata quella
digitale per la scuola con un bacco a
mano e ritrovandomi la preside davanti
invece di chiedere scusa di andarmene
spettatori scappare con questo banco e
sane idee due piani di scale era il
momento che sono state in seguito dai
bidelli ho messo il banco come blocco
per i bidelli chiaramente trincerato
della scuola oppure erano di una
lentezza e bidelli dire che era vivo tu
non hai niente di stupido a raccontare
non era stupita san domeni geniale
questa cosa abbiamo fatto ecco secondo
me tu pensi che siano geniale coppa
quando lady rai ti renderai conto sono
adatte al tema una volta con una mia
amica andiamo a mcdonald a mangiare e
amo voglia di altro cibo cioè ma cosa ci
siamo sfondati pesante mi pesantemente e
ci vergognavamo a far vedere gravano
sempre lui e quindi abbiamo iniziato a
travestirsi per non farci riconoscere da
chi tra vestiti come con gli occhiali
mentre l'effetto clark kent cioè
cambiavi la riga mettere gli occhiali
questa ragione al e forse dc tutte le
cose in geniali che è stata pazzesca
possiamo dove il nome questa amica da
allora la presente in questo no perché
poi dopo non è più riconosciuta non si
sa cosa sia la mente bene perché abbiamo
un canale slingbox e facciamo tanti
formati incredibili linking descrizione
l'indiscrezione che tu mi passi no
perché io mi fa piacere cioè se vieni a
farmi un favoloso il mio canale giusto
date sul canale s'indossa pericolo cosa
lei ma non siete qui
il mio fratelli diciamo quello mezzano
quello più casinista di noi
ebbe l'idea di andare a rubare dal
contadino vicino le angurie e comodo
andando a rubare questi giorni dove
prendere 123 contadino si svegliò ho
preso il fucile e spara letteralmente i
miei fratelli scappato io rimasi lì con
un imbecille che accadono misure che
veramente mi presi mi portò a mia madre
non vi dico le botti che ci hanno dato è
tutta l'estate i miei genitori continua
il messaggio dicendovi che tra qualche
mese faccio due anni di matrimonio con
la figlia del contadino c'hanno siete
fortissimi vigna alla fine hai rubato al
contadino la cosa più importante la sua
anguria più importante per sua figlia e
ogni giorno vedono la persona che mi ha
sparato alla milza passati dai genitori
un po esagerati se mio figlio
scopro che finisce nel giardino di un
agricoltore magari anche in un paesino
dove un agricoltore c'è il fucile pure
in casa e per rubarsi dell'anguria e
rischia di essere sparato io pago le
angurie al contadino e yen in fila 11
lo aspetto a dire lo scivolo con
l'anguria spera ci staro male quando sei
piccolo io l'ho fatto io pure frutta 6
aladino sono praticamente quello che
facevo io era rubare i singoli chicchi
d'uva passavo rubare ticket dovuto per
stupidità invitavi rita levi montalcini
che di aver rubato circa 50 euro di uva
via ai scavato un solco di casa avanti
al contadino tu cosa hai rubato una se
lor moon a una mia compagna alle
elementari
sailor moon poi non l'ho più ritrovata
secondo me li ha restituiti ma un
peccato perché mi aveva trovata e mi ha
detto ma perché ce l'ha in me l'hanno
regalata e dissi veramente regalata non
era vero molto bene non sono al corrente
o mostro due anni curiose l'ormone non
sapevo come fare subito bene così tutti
vedranno che è il pigiama che poi
artigiano anche sovrani che aveva dubbio
tu riesca cosa htc quattro anni
abbracciate un cactus
penso che possa bastare per sempre
rimaste incastrate ovviamente poi la
fina sessualità nel tempo fosse che poi
è il politico umberto ponzo vale a dire
possa soffusa ci stai non mandare un
vocale se sempre dal palco dalle quindi
poi ha ributtato giu il suo vomito liana
cosa è una cosa tremenda
poi questi non so cosa stupire bravo
solo per la stessa lo sa come stupire è
imbarazzante
tante però zia sia da umida abomini che
lui che ha fatto la cosa più stupida
parte chissà chi se no no ed è costata
urlare uscita dalla piscina ma no che
gli ficchi la mano in bocca ed eletta
vomitando che quando metti la mano
avanti al tubo dell'acqua e poi l'acqua
comincia a professare quindi fa effetto
questo rosone di momi o diventiamo
quanti vi prego grave però
no però aspettano basta avete presente
voices battitori quelli elettrici quelli
tipo anche per il cappuccino con il
cappuccino che vibrano tutti no avevo
bevuto ma non tanto un po ho pensato che
fosse molto intelligente in quel momento
patente c'era questa mia amica che la
seduta io le case quando si possa
ceramico il demonio io ho fatto solo
questo
rega si è creato questo luogo di
scindibile che è salito lungo tutto il
frullino praticate da reato dentro al
motore credo che detto al cranio
erano tutti ubriachi siamo stati neanche
capaci di togliere lo vincerà lei tenuta
da un amico di peso con la testa sul
tavolo pensa così e due persone che
provano a tirare questo frullino 6
capelli e la società che vedono tagliati
la ciocca intera perché se un collocare
ammazzato se fossi stata in lei
ciao ciao ospite con l'amico era la nota
tutto un euro
girando ho visto delle forbici che non
erano proprio dalla punta arrotondata
ecco a canal per scherzare mi sono
girato e cominciamo accusa è chiara la
pancia della persona dietro di me ho
detto mazza guarda molto sono affilate
queste forbici ti potrei accoltellare
mentre punto è che ho mi accorgo che è
comunque il mio amico che pensavo fosse
il mio amico aveva una pancia molto
grosso detto mi hai messo su peso a
questa pancia da dove spunta alzato lo
sguardo mi sono accorto che stavo
punzecchiando la pancia un'altra persona
un armadio che mi fissava con aria molto
molesta con
sul collo niente mi sono calato addosso
che so scusa sono notorie pio che ancora
però penso fisse molto peggio non
pensavo che le forbici sarebbero uscite
ma come ti viene però di provare delle
forbici spoon seccando le in pancia
qualcuno posso dire l'ultima cosa
stupida poi digiuno ma di farlo mai più
vede proprio simile a questa allora
gallipoli discoteca io questo mio amico
che siamo tra la folla camminando
insieme si sempre un po alticci vediamo
questa cubista che era una cubista
pazzesca avrebbero pensato chi yukino in
questo avvio pazzesca un'opera d'arte in
fondo schiena
quindi cosa faccio io prendo questo mio
amico e faccio un urlo fortissimo tipo
così se non fosse che mentre faccio così
guardo avanti a me e trema davanti a me
c'era il mio amico ti sei mai solo
questo colpo davanti a me perché pensavo
fosse il mio amico per fare con la
classica persona e che se vedesse in
discoteca vorrei andare nel posto dove
quella persona il vicinato
io non mi emoziono di solito ben era
veramente pazzesco dopo una bicicletta
quel giorno non solo le voci una volta
faceva la cubista
[Risate]
si no
quel giorno non stavo fosse un po male
di stomaco non ricordo bene mamma ha
visto queste biciclette bellissimi ad
ottenere questo vino bianco l'ho provata
bellissima comoda ovviamente il negozio
solo con commessi maschi scendendo dalla
bicicletta e sul sellino bianco la
striscia del maine e raccordi mai che
già nel sellino meglio circa quattro
anni pero da mia nonna aspettato di lei
si allontanasse e in quel minuto sono
corsa in balcone ho preso il sacco
dell'immondizia nero bello pesante è
lanciato dal balcone colpendo una
macchina che stava passando di ritrova
saint bon ton
io sono un po sconvolto ma labbra tutte
le parti che dove denti fossero così
tanti seguono severo grazie nel bel
mezzo della mia pubertà mentre guardava
la televisione ho iniziato a intravedere
mezza poppa della clerici ea loro deciso
beh cacchio già che ci siamo posso farmi
una pipa e allora ho preso un po di
carta igienica ho iniziato a lavorare
bene mentre guardavo la clerici che
cucinava che si vedesse chissà quanto
però per me all'epoca era qualcosa di
assurdo list non avevo ancora internet a
casa quello era il massimo che potevo
aspirare che purtroppo facciamo
continuamente degli stacchi di
pubblicità quindi mi interrompeva non
riuscivo ad arrivare fino alla fine
quando ormai stavo per finire sempre un
rumore jury guarda dalla finestra c'era
un tizio con un camioncino questo
elettricista stava aggiustando ligio da
basso quindi non mi sono preoccupato e
ho continuato imperterrito purtroppo un
certo punto mentre ero proprio
vicinissimi si nissim missin sento
rumore fortissimo la finestra dov'ero io
giro a rallentatore è un trauma e vedo
sto tizio alla finestra aggiustando un
pezzo già da almeno dieci minuti
paralizzato mi sono buttato sul
pavimento i sono strascinato nell'altra
stanza senza tirarmi su i pantaloni con
gli sommessa piano ha comunque sollevato
da terra campo trotto dai moti pompas
poraccio la clerici paura che io posso
dire io vado tutto quanto il mio affetto
ad antonella ragazzi siamo arrivati alla
fine di questo video io vi ringrazio
mi scuso io vi ringrazio persone che
hanno visto che io vi ringrazio invece
ogni volta per contribuire diciamo alla
realizzazione di vita buttata senza i
vostri commenti non esisterebbe questo
format ma in realtà nemmeno senza più
prezioso aiuto dei miei ospiti quindi
marco ti ringrazio per essere regole non
succeda più quelli sì ma stato
immaginato io so già tutto workshop
prima di salutarvi vi ricordo che se
siete dei lettori se state cercando un
club del libro fate un salto sulla setta
dei libri su instagram
a noi fa solamente che piacere avere più
persone con le quali condividere la
lettura è quello che facciamo insieme ai
vari adepti che altro dire iscrivetevi a
questo canale
mettete un like commentate con altri va
della campanella attivate la campanella
è bravissimo e soprattutto fateci sapere
qual è la cosa per stupire avete fatto e
andate a fare un salto nel canale
dell'asl i blocks ciao ciao